[Music]
joanne is in raleigh north carolina hi
joanne welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave and george thank you for taking
my call and god bless you both for
everything you do i appreciate it well
thank you you too how can we help
well um
my husband's 75 i'm 65 both retired uh
we sold our house in raleigh last
september
when the market was great thought we
would be full-time rv years
have been touring the country since then
and have found
that's not the life for us
so we would like to have a home date
so we've already made a deal
contracted for a brand new house
near raleigh and
it's about four hundred thousand
we have 180 in a money market account
and
another well it used to be a hundred in
an investment
um account and that's gone down
to 94 000 which is kind of sickening us
um so we wondered what your advice would
be should we
put all that money towards
the 400 000 house
i mean it was a paid for house that we
sold what did it sell for we've been
following
325.
okay
and so you you and you've still got 280
what's the rv worth
uh about
you gonna sell it
no we were gonna take it up to new york
where we have our son and wife and
grandchildren and spend the summers in
it up
at a there
okay
all right
um that sounds fun
okay
it is
and how much do you have in retirement
accounts
well
it's i'm retired from new york and north
carolina and then with both of our
social securities we get about
a little over 7 000 a month yeah but do
you have a retirement nest eggs
no
so you don't have like 401ks or
something like that
no it was all state retirement okay so
you have a good steady income but if you
but this 280 000 between the uh
investment and the cash is all you've
got
yeah
okay
so i thought you said you were going to
pull money out of retirement to pay for
the house how are you doing this no no
the investment account we were wondering
if we should leave that in there no you
should put it all in the house
you should put it in the house you have
a really big monthly income
yeah i know we're black we are very
blessed yeah
and i would use that in you make sure
you keep an emergency fund back and
let's put as much down on the house as
we can and then i want you to work to
get that house paid off as quick as you
can
yeah yeah
i don't i don't want you listen i don't
want you married to an 85 year old man
still have a mortgage
i know you know we love you we've been
following you for 10 years you know
actually came and saw you you know in
2013 and um you know you've changed our
life already but i think you know we
feel like we may have done
something a little stupid here but um
just i just wanted to
hear you call it another option is buy a
280 000 house instead of a 400 000 house
well we've already contracted for this
new
bid on a couple here in raleigh and um
it is crazy there the bidding wars
they're going for one house just one for
sixty thousand dollars more than that
price yeah i know
okay well that's the thing i mean
because i i'm not
i mean we are not thrilled with the idea
of you going into the last years of your
retirement in the next two decades with
house payments so i want you to clear
that house payment on that 400 as quick
as you can get that emergency fund set
aside some money for closing costs the
rest is going to be a big old down
payment so you have as little mortgage
as possible so that you can attack it as
quickly as possible that would be my
goal sitting on 130 140 000 worth of
debt and so how quick do you pay that
off with you know 8 000 a month income
so yeah you're going to pay it off but
you do need to do it in like three or
four years you don't you don't need to
mess around with this
and uh because you want to get back to
where you were with that paid for
property and then
uh keep keeping that rv and then moving
it up in there and having your summers
around the grandkids is a cool idea so
but let's let's have a plan to knock
this little mortgage out it's going to
be a little one and let's get it done
and then start building some investment
dollars beyond that
beyond just your monthly income i'd love
for you to have another half million
dollars in a few years and you've got
the ability to do all that but you're
just going to have to concentrate and
focus here so
uh that would be an interesting note
because we have a whole lot of people
that that's their dream
it's an rv it comes up uh comes up a lot
sell the house i'm a rv
sell the house i'm all rv we get that
from people of all ages and i'm gonna rv
around the country i'm an rv around the
country and um
uh
the moral of the story is it's not for
everyone
and this idea that it's always glamorous
uh no it's not no it's not it's an rv
it's fun and there's an adventure part
to it but it it does it can wear thin
and it obviously did with them and
they're you know they're parking the
thing yeah and uh so and and it's you
know the
the false start of it cost them
something there so
um
if we had their situation to do over
we'd probably say buy a good used rv and
go on the road before you sell your
house
and make sure that the test run make
sure that life is what you want before
you in this hot market people are going
should i sell my house and just live in
an rv because i can get so much for the
house right now no you shouldn't because
it might not be what you want to do
so you ought to go give it a try and
that's why you try a pair of shoes on
see if they fit you know this is a plan